one so who does shake milton guard  that's gonna be fascinating interesting  part of the match-ups and strategy going  into that series and  that's a foul on embiid who took  exception  to the non-call and that's his fifth  foul  so he may just use up all his fouls and  call it a night  [Music]  take one more look at what happened  embiid wanted a call right there and  then commits the foul  and a technical foul against him too  [Music]  what is he shooting free throws for  did they ever blow a whistle i missed  that okay it's a technical against  james harden  i mean if anything first of all you  could call that first one you could call  that second one too  but what joelle did i mean that's the  non-basketball play  i thought the tank was gonna be on  the the technical foul was on harden for  throwing the ball at mv just watch him  he's angry  so he b-lines i mean i i guess it's not  a technical but that's not a basketball  play  and if i'm james i'm angry